you hear President Trump tell it trade
wars are easy to win other people who
ever think they are best avoided in the
Oval Office today with Israel's prime
minister President Trump was standing
his ground on the threat of imposing
tariffs on foreign aluminum and steel no
we're not backing down
we lost 800 billion dollars a year on
trade not gonna happen we got to get it
back opposition to the president's plan
is growing today Speaker Paul Ryan
voiced his concerns in a statement from
his press aide saying we are extremely
worried about the consequences of a
trade war and are urging the White House
did not advance with this plan the new
tax reform law has boosted the economy
and we certainly don't want to
jeopardize those gains we have a great
relationship with speaker Ryan we're
gonna continue to have one but that
doesn't mean we have to agree on
everything President Trump played down
the notion that he may ignite a trade
war I don't think
but he warned America's trading partners
he would take punitive action if they
retaliate the European Union we can't do
business in it and if they want to do
something we'll just tax their cars that
they send in here like water the
president appeared to give America's
closest neighbors a possible out
tweeting today NAFTA which is under
renegotiation right now has been a bad
deal for us a tariffs on steel and
aluminum will only come off if new and
fair NAFTA agreement is signed president
george w bush exempt in canada and
mexico from steel tariffs in 2002
which eventually dropped tariffs
altogether in the face of punishing
retaliation from US trade allies Bush's
former chief of staff Josh Bolten now
with the Business Roundtable says going
there again would be a big mistake
this will cause huge damage across broad
sectors of the economy you may be will
be able to give a little bit of help to
the steel and aluminum industries you're
gonna cause damage across any number of
downstream industries and any number of
industries that export to countries that
are likely to retaliate in his talks
with Prime Minister Netanyahu today
President Trump focused on trade but
also Iran and the again stalled Middle
East peace process but what they really
wanted to talk about was moving the u.s.
embassy to Jerusalem in May many
presidents were discussing whether or
not to make that decision and they
promised it in their campaigns but they
never were able to do what they should
have done so I was able to do it mr.
president this will be remembered by our
people but the president revealed today
he was stunned by the price tag he
recently received for the embassy move
they put an order in front of my desk
last week for a billion dollars I said a
billion what's that for we're gonna
build an embassy I said we're not gonna
spend a billion dollars and we're
actually doing it for about two hundred
and fifty thousand dollars so check that
out now it's temporary but it'll be very
nice 250,000 dollars versus a billion
dollars was that good the key to saving
money there is that word the president
used temporary he's going to save money
by moving ambassador David Friedman and
a small staff to the existing US
consulate in Jerusalem that will only
require a small amount of construction
but the long-term plan is still to build
a new embassy so the president may need
that billion dollars after all Janet
yeah $250,000 sounds like a very
conservative estimate Sean thank you
very much